Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Linus. Guten Morgen Tim. Endlich.
Da ist sie die dreiundzwanzig. Wir haben noch nicht mal eine passende Verschwörungstheorie am Start.
Mal gucken.
Ja, wir hatten jetzt eine Woche Pause ausnahmsweise mal. Ich glaube, das ist das erste Mal, dass uns das so passiert ist. Abgesehen von so ein paar Tagesverschiebungen, äh Wochenrhythmus.
Das ist richtig, es war und wir haben es nicht hingekriegt. Oder wir wir wollten auch irgendwann nicht mehr. Wir wollten lieber äh.
Ja, wir hatten ins Auge gefasst zu senden. Das haben wir auch glaube ich äh latent angekündigt, aber wie das immer so ist, auf solchen Konferenzen, es ist so viel los und trallala und äh.
So viele nette Leute und also Republika dieses Jahr, ich war hier gerade noch vorher gesagt, ich will hier nicht schon wieder so ein Republikast machen. Das haben wir jetzt alle durchgesprochen, aber republikat dieses Jahr war,
unglaublich gut. Also vom vom wieder der der Drive so war. Ja. Spitze.
Ja. Spitze. Da war schwer was los.
War echt, wie schön, dass da abends war, mit allen irgendwie zu stehen und so, also.
Also ich war, ich muss sagen, ich bin,
schon ein paar Mal gesagt, ich bin nicht wirklich im eigentlichen Sinne überrascht gewesen von der Veranstaltung. Also alles das, was da passiert ist ähm,
passte in mein Bild, wie ich das bisher, wie ich diese Veranstaltung bisher gesehen habe und wie ich die Entwicklung dieser Veranstaltung bisher gesehen habe,
Es gab natürlich keine Garantie dafür, dass es dann auch wirklich so erhalten hat kommen müssen
Ja, die Location hätte irgendwelche dramatischen Probleme aufwerfen können et cetera. Es hätte ja auch sein können, was ich gar nicht wusste
dass die äh Logistik, die Orga irgendwie sich äh äh bekämpft, das scheint alles nicht eingetreten zu sein und so konnte sich das voll entfachen. Und es war eigentlich so, wie bei der ersten,
Wo irgendwie so alle grinsend im Hof standen und eigentlich total überrascht waren von sich und von dem Event.
Noch in der Kalkscheune, das da war auch so ein so ein irres Gefühl irgendwie im Raum und zwar auch so dieses war so total klar, diese Veranstaltung hat sich bereits etabliert. Es war irgendwie nach der ersten Republik war das irgendwie logisch,
So habe ich das empfunden zumindest und so kam's aber letztlich auch. Und diesmal mit der neuen Location,
Ja, da entscheidet sich halt immer wieder aufs Neue so, okay, ist das jetzt noch die Veranstaltung, wie wir sie kennen, obwohl sie Ort gewechselt hat und natürlich auch ich weiß nicht, die Teilnehmerzahl war ja auch letztes Jahr schon nicht gering, aber es ist schon ist schon noch mal ange,
ist auf jeden Fall. Und was halt äh äh diesmal ganz wunderbar dazukam, was letzte Mal einfach gefehlt hat, war einfach dieser eine Ort.
Genau, ich wollte grad sagen, also eigentlich fand ich mit der mit der Location mit dem Motto-Wechsel war's eigentlich kein großartiges Risiko. Ähm New Thinking kennt ja diese Location, die betreuen die ja auch sonst, mit äh WLAN und und Spielereien
ähm das heißt Newthinking kennt die kennt die Location, kennt die Veranstaltung, die da stattfinden und ähm,
eigentlich, was kannst du an, also was früher diese Location, was war das Friedrichstadtpalast, Quatsch, Club und wie hieß das dritte Ding da,
Dieses andere Gebäude, was da noch dabei war, Pipapo, Kalkshot, ne? Ja.
Und dann gab's auch einmal noch dieses merkwürdige Business-Center, was daneben ist, aber das war wohl nicht so gut.
Also was war da, was war das für ein für ein also außer diesen schönen palastartigen Saal eins, der dir da geboten wird im im äh Friedrichstadtpalast. Was war denn daran gut? Da war doch sonst alles Quatsch da. Voll locationmäßig. Insofern.
Quatsch Comedy Club fand ich auch ganz gemütlich eigentlich. Aber es war halt alles,
voneinander entfernt. Es war nicht klar, wo man sich trifft, et cetera, wenn man in der Kalksteine war, statt man da im Hof, wenn man äh Friedrichstadtpalast war, stand man in der Mitte oder davor,
und so weiter. Ja, ja.
Denn du jetzt gerade wieder.
Und jetzt gab's eher nur noch so das Draußen oder drinnen, aber das war auch direkt nebeneinander. Also das war schon eine tolle Sache und es war trotzdem interessant, wie,
ähm ja, wie nach wie vor die Politik, auch die Netzpolitik dort äh äh nach wie vor präsent war und ist ja auch ein paar Sachen passiert, die wir jetzt die Ehre haben, hier in einer neuen Ausgabe von Politik,
durch den Fleischwolf zu ziehen. Womit legen wir also los.
Ja, wir bleiben am besten direkt bei der äh Republika, denn da war ja dieses Mal, also es war ja wirklich eine eine Reihe an illustren Gästen darunter. Naley Cruise. Wir erinnern uns, die äh EU-Kommissarin,
und äh die hat irgendwie einen Vortrag gehalten, ich habe ihn selber nicht gesehen, weil ich würde ja niemals mir einen Vorteil von Nelly Cruise angucken und äh sie hat aber dann gesagt, äh das wurde dann sehr wohl in den Medien rezipiert, macht euch,
um Acta keine Sorgen mehr.
Und ähm also man müsste sich keine Sorgen mehr deshalb machen. Jetzt ist aber irgendwie nicht klar,
woher sie das wissen will, weil sie ist ja EU-Kommissarin und Akta steht jetzt erstmal vor der Abstimmung im Parlament. Jetzt darf man natürlich davon ausgehen, dass sie sich viel mit den Leuten unterhält,
ähm aber ähm Fehler für einen Verakter ist eigentlich dieser Karrelle Gurt, der ist Verfechter von Acta und der,
Ähm also wie gesagt, eigentlich liegt's im EU-Parlament und der Berichterstatter dort ist der David Martin oder David Martin, keine Ahnung,
und ähm der hat sich zwar gegen die Ratifizierung ausgesprochen, aber äh nur weil er gerne Nachbesserungen hätte. Also ja, dann haben wir noch die äh Mariel Gallo,
die ist natürlich total dafür und ich weiß nicht, also ich fand's ein bisschen erstaunlich, dass sie sich da so hinstellt und sagt, äh macht euch mal keine Sorgen mehr. Weil was wäre der Schluss, den man daraus ziehen soll, wenn Neli Cruise sagt, macht euch keine Sorgen? Soll ich da mit dem Protestieren aufhören?
Ähm,
Ja, also äh warum sagt sie das frag ich.
Also sie hat das nicht weiter erläutert.
Nee, nicht wirklich, ja, sie hat halt gesagt, ja, äh, das hat sich jetzt rumgesprochen, dass das ist und,
da brauchen wir uns keine Sorgen mehr drum zu machen. Vielleicht auch so ein bisschen beruhigend oder so. Aber ich denke halt irgendwie für eine für eine große Meldung äh ist mir,
Also ich möchte gerne einfach die Entscheidung im im EU-Parlament haben und dann kann man sagen, okay, jetzt ist dieser,
dieser Drops gelutscht. Aber äh weil Neli Cruise auf der Republika sagt, macht euch keine Sorgen mehr, das geht nicht durch. Ja, da wäre ich äh erstmal vorsichtiger.
Das sind nicht die Druinen, die ihr sucht.
Und dann gab's ja genau da das äh war noch ganz interessant. Ähm dann gab's ja die Anhörung im äh Bundestag zu der Petition,
Und da äh,
Ist dann der Markus Beckerdive von gegangen und ähm das das wurde also live übertragen, glaube ich, diese Anhörung ins ins Internet,
und Markus ging irgendwie rein mit seinem faltete seinen Laptop auf und wollte irgendwie live bloggen und wurde dann ähm.
Äh zurechtgewiesen, Berichterstattung sei nur für akkreditierte Presse erlaubt.
Und er möge doch jetzt bitte irgendwie Laptop zuklappen. Dann hat er irgendwie seinen Hausausweis rausgeholt und meinte, ja, ich bin aber hier Enquete-Kommission und dann sagten die, ja äh eben
Ist aber nur für akkreditierte Presse. Bitte lassen sie sein. Also Ding wird live ins Internet gestreamt. Ja, also was äh was denken, was erlauben ja? Wie kann man kann man so blöd sein bei irgendwie dem Haupt ähm
dem Gesicht äh der oder der Person, die sich in den letzten halben Jahr so zum Gesicht des Protestes in Deutschland,
herauskristallisiert hat. Markus Beckedal, ja, mit dem Verein digitale Gesellschaft und mit Netzpolitik org. Und mit dieser Klage, mit Matthias Schindler, auf Herausgabe, äh, dieser Information über die Geheimverhandlung,
wer ist da im Bundestag beschäftigt, um zu dem hinzugehen, zu sagen, du darfst jetzt hier nicht live bloggen.
Aber wer hat es ihm denn konkret untersagt.
Was weiß ich, Saalschutz oder oder.
Sicherheitsdienst.
Irgendwie auch. So.
Schränke, die da irgendwie im Anzug rum.
So Schränke sind das ja gar nicht im Bundestag. Also da ist die ja vielleicht eher so Klappschränke oder so,
Ja
Genau und dann dann durfte er nicht live rocken, dann hat er sich aber irgendwie unten in den Bereich zu den Abgeordneten gesetzt, weil ihn dann irgendjemand da runtergeschleust hat. Und da ging's dann wohl. Äh und da wurde dann, sagte der Staatssekretär vom,
Justizministerium Max Stadler. Äh ja,
Die Bundesregierung hätte ja seit Anfang des Jahres gewusst, dass Akta im EU-Parlament keine Mehrheit erhielte und deswegen
hätte jetzt Sabine die Unterschrift erstmal ausgesetzt und
um die Sache irgendwie auch kalt zu stellen und so. Ähm,
recht erstaunlich, dass das jetzt alle auf einmal so sagen, ja ja, wissen wir ja, dass das EU-Parlament das ab äh lehnt. So. Bin ich mir äh also ich möchte nicht sagen, dass es nicht so ist, aber ich bin erstaunt, dass jetzt auf einmal alle behaupten, dass sie von Anfang an gewusst hätten. Ähm.
Ja, die suchen alle irgendwie den Notausgang, habe ich.
Ja genau, muss man sich jetzt auch überlegen, wenn er auf einmal hunderttausend Leute auf der Straße sind? Da denkt sich jeder Berufspolitiker, irgendwie so, wo ist es nochmal irgendwie gucken?
Was wie kommen wir aus der Nummer wieder raus?
Noch schöne Randnotiz der Vertreter vom Bundesministerium für wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit sagte, dass die Bundesregierung keinem
Entwicklungsland empfehlen würde ACA zuzustimmen. Das war ja immer etwas, was ich hier unter auch im Logbuch Netzpolitik habe anklingen lassen. Was Acta fürs Internet bedeutet, ist ein Kinka-Litzchen im Vergleich dazu, was das für den
Handel und äh die das Heilen von Krankheiten armer Menschen bedeuten könnte, wenn wenn das da durchgesetzt wird,
Also sieht erstmal ganz gut aus, aber Entwarnung gibt.
Man muss jetzt sagen, also sowohl also der Max Stadler ist ein Justizministerium.
Ja, der ist da äh Staatssekretär.
Und das Bundesministerium für wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit wird wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit.
Entwicklungshilfe und Wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit ist das, glaube ich, ne?
Davon redest. Also auch, dass das Nebel, das FDP, geführte. Also wir reden jetzt.
Ja genau, aber das offensichtlich auch der nein Vertreter oder Staatssekretär davon. Ich habe das jetzt nur aus Markus äh Text äh notiert.
Ja gut, ich wollte das nur so äh konkretisieren. Nicht, dass man jetzt denkt, wir reden vom Wirtschaftsministerium. Nee.
Nehmen. Also es, ich glaube, das ist doch dann genau nie beendet äh wird äh Entwicklungshilfe und wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit müsste das sein, ne?
Ja, also.
FDP noch präsent ist.
Ist FDP, FDP, ist auch so ein Ding, ja. Ähm.
Genau, wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit und Entwicklung ist ja korrekte äh.
Aha, Entwicklung, ja, Entwicklungshilfe wäre äh zu übel als Name für Minister.
Ähm.
Ja, also irgendwie,
Man weiß nicht so ganz genau, ob das jetzt alles äh äh Nebelkerzen sind oder ob die einfach schon mal nochmal versuchen, so ein Rettungsboot auf der Titanic äh zu finden. Trotzdem stellt sich äh irgendwie der Eindruck ein,
dass das Boot Acta mindestens schon mal ordentlich
geschlagen ist. Ist da auf so 'n Eisberg gefahren, den sie irgendwie so richtig nicht am kommen sehen und dessen größer und Vehemenz ihnen auch nicht so ganz klar war, nicht wahr? Es fing mit Polen an und vielleicht war es damit auch schon irgendwie vorbei, ne?
Man kann es vielleicht echt vergleichen mit äh ja mit Titanic, dass sie da erstmal noch so sitzen und denken sich so, ah äh bewahren sie Ruhe. Bewahren sie Ruhe.
Modernste Boot. Waren sie Ruhe? Uns kann keiner was.
Und äh ja und die Band spielt bis zum Schluss oder? Adios, hey, ja ähm.
Ah, jetzt sitzen sie und treiben da auf irgend so eine Eisschale durch die Gegend und wissen nicht, wie ihnen geschah.
Ähm
die Crowdfunding Sache von digitale Gesellschaft, da wurde ja noch mal viel oder viel ja wurden einige tausend Euro über betterplace äh zusammengekratzt. Äh der CCC hat an digitale Gesellschaft auch nochmal dreitausend Euro gespendet
für Materialien, zur Aufklärung und Pandemisierung in äh in Brüssel
Acta, um eben sicherzustellen, dass die Abgeordneten da eine vernünftige Entscheidung treffen,
und ich denke, das ist ähm also,
Von solchen Aktionen sollte man sich nicht abhalten lassen, weil irgendwie Gruß oder äh Mark Stadler irgendwas äh sagen.
Nee, ich denke, das ist jetzt eigentlich auch genau der richtige Zeitpunkt. Ich meine, wenn der Gegner da ohnehin schon wankt, dann ähm ist natürlich der Punkt gekommen, da dann auch wirklich nachzutreten
weil äh es geht ja hier gar nicht jetzt so sehr um,
Das Paket ActA, es geht halt um den Inhalt und man darf jetzt nicht so blauäugig sein, zu glauben, dass damit irgendwie alle in diesem Paket zusammen geschnürten Inhalte automatisch äh auf dem Weg nach draußen sind
Das wird halt jetzt neu gestreut werden auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise.
Also der Vergleich nachtreten ähm,
trifft da sehr gut zu, weil man tritt ja deshalb nach, weil man möchte, dass der andere nicht mehr aufsteht, ja. Und ähm das wäre dann hier geboten. Hoffentlich ganz physische Vergleiche, äh nur ungern äh heranziehe.
Okay, dann benehmen wir uns beim nächsten Thema einfach ein bisschen mehr sprachlich.
Genau.
Ist denn das nächste.
Nächste Thema ist ein schönes Thema. Da können wir uns sehr äh sehr benehmen. Äh und zwar die Niederländer,
Die Niederlande wollte ich eigentlich sagen. Und jetzt die Niederländer. Ähm die haben jetzt Netznetralität. Und zwar ähm als
Gesetzesentwurf, der den Senat auch passiert hat. Das äh ging, glaube ich, los irgendwie zweitausendelf, da wurde dann so ein Gesetzesentwurf abgesprochen,
von äh abgehakt vom Parlament
in dem dann so Sachen drin standen wie ja es darf nicht in keiner Form irgendwie in den Traffic eines Internetnutzers eingegriffen werden, es sei denn,
ähm das ist in dessen Interesse und er ist darüber informiert oder hat das quasi, wollte das so. Und ähm insbesondere darf man nicht irgendwie verlangsamen oder blockieren, gar nix.
Und ähm das ist jetzt erstmal auf dem besten Wege dort gesetzt zu werden. Und das ist natürlich eine sehr äh erfreuliche Maßnahme. Also das.
Bezieht sich das jetzt erstmal nur so auf Bandbreiten oder äh was also geht das jetzt hier nur um diesen Klassiker der der Geschwindigkeitssteuerung, der Gleichbehandlung der Pakete auf dem Rauterwege oder schließt das dann auch so Sachen wie Portblocking Dienstesperren mit allen Skype auf Mobilfunknetzen et cetera.
Also es würde es wäre, es scheint von dem, was ich ähm da jetzt gelesen habe. Ähm,
Genau, also man könnte ja jetzt, ist ja sowieso erstmal schwer, Netzneutralität jetzt wirklich zu definieren. Nehmen wir mal diese einfache Arbeitsdefinition, jedes TCP-Paket ist gleich
und der Provider hat da nichts nach Inhalt zu unterscheiden. Äh oder nach nach Port, äh also weder nach nach Quelle, noch nach Ziel, noch nach Inhalt äh irgendwo noch nach Port oder sonstwas irgendwie zu differenzieren,
und ähm das scheint ja jetzt erstmal so der ähm.
Der Punkt zu sein. Sie machen halt die Ausnahme, dass sie sagen, okay, im Interesse des Nutzers
Ja, also wenn wenn ich einen persönlichen Vorteil dadurch habe, dass irgendwie ähm ist ja dieses häufige total hinkende Beispiel mit der E-Mail
die die das YouTube Video flackern lässt oder ruckeln lässt. Das ist natürlich also ist ja ziemlicher Unsinn, Netzneutralität ist ja eher ein Problem auf der Ebene darüber, nicht wie die
wie die Pakete bei mir ankommen, sondern wie meine Pakete mit denen,
anderer Nutzer konkurrieren. Das ist ja eigentlich das das Problem bei Netzneutralität. Und,
Dass ein weiteres großes Problem dabei, wie,
Beispielsweise die Pakete eines Anbieters, mit denen eines anderen konkurrieren, das beispielsweise ähm jetzt muss ich mal einen Vergleich machen, äh eins und eins gehört ja dieses Maxdome.
Und jetzt könnte natürlich die Telekom,
Das irgendwie kannst du online irgendwie Fernsehen gucken. Komm, Filme, so ein Streaming, Streaming-Service, ja? Ähm oder so eine Bibliothek wie, nee, wie heißt das, Videothek oder so? Kannst du sagen, ich möchte jetzt den und den Film gucken?
Und ähm jetzt könnt ihr natürlich sein, dass das die Telekom Interesse daran hat, dass das bei ihnen im Netz ruckelt,
auf das die Nutzer ähm keine Verträge mit äh Maxdome eingehen, sondern Verträge mit der Telekom für ihr Entertainer,
Ähm das sind ja eher so die die grausigen ähm,
Aspekte der äh Netzneutralität oder der Verletzten Netzneutralität. Auch das äh ist natürlich ausgeschlossen, weil das nicht im Interesse des Nutzers wäre.
Ähm,
also Blockade und verlangsamen. Er klärt sich dann von selbst, ist auch nicht im Interesse des Nutzers. Also es sieht ja erstmal alles ganz ordentlich aus, dann haben sie sich auch noch irgendwie um ähm,
mein niederländisch ist leider auch nicht so gut, haben sie sich auch noch äh um Cookies gekümmert, das würde ich jetzt mal gerne außen vor lassen, weil sie da auch so ein bisschen ähm.
Also diese äh Datenschutz äh E-Commerce-Richtlinien oder was das da war, äh mit Datenschutz im Internet oder so, haben sie auch noch irgendwie mit reingenommen, aber da will ich jetzt gar nicht irgendwie ähm.
Ich jetzt gar nicht so drauf eingehen. Also fest steht so, die haben,
da ein vernünftiges Netzertalitätsgesetz durch Parlament und Senat gebracht und jetzt muss noch die zweite Kammer kann jetzt nochmal quasi minimale Änderungs
Änderungen daran vornehmen. Da steht auch noch eine aus. Da war irgendwie Einsatz, sollte da noch geändert werden, weil jetzt eine
kleinere Angelegenheit und dann scheint es tatsächlich so zu sein, dass die äh Netzneutralität festgeschrieben haben. Und dann braucht da keiner mehr zu kommen und zu sagen, mach mal hier ähm sperr mal hier Pirate Bay oder so,
oder äh drosselt mal äh oder sonstige Sachen, ne? Oder äh da wird's dann auch spannend,
Eigentlich dürfte dann auch kein Mobilfunk Provider mehr Skype blockieren. Da weiß ich nicht genau äh
wie das äh sich damit verhält, wie ob das Niederländische Mobilfunk Provider machen oder nicht. Aber äh streng genommen, so wie ich das Gesetz lese, wird das wäre das dann auch nicht mehr in Ordnung,
Ähm weiterhin, was sie noch drin haben, das fand ich sehr spannend, ist also DPI, die
Package Inspection, was eigentlich notwendig ist für eine,
für sage ich mal eine differenziertere Verletzung der Netzneutralität, muss ich halt in Paketinhalte reinschauen.
Das haben sie verboten, sofern nicht der Nutzer.
Ist klar, dass er es verbietet, weil warum sollte das noch einer machen, wenn eh Netzneutralität zu herrschen hat? Es sei denn, der Nutzer stimmt dem zu,
Das äh sollte der Nutzer eigentlich nicht tun,
Es sei denn, er lässt sich auf bestimmte Zusatzservices an, die auch in den Niederlanden ganz beliebt sind oder da jetzt auch implementiert werden. Und auch in Deutschland zum Beispiel bei einigen Providern
und in England auch bei einigen Pro Weilern schon gemacht werden. Das zum Beispiel irgendwie geguckt wird, ob das Smartphone,
infiziert ist oder so,
und dass man quasi sagt, also dein Smartphone scheint infiziert zu sein, dieser Traffic ist nicht in deinem Interesse, du hast das Häkchen gemacht bei ähm.
Verstehe.
Bei Virenschutz.
Genau, solche, solche Scherze. Das wäre also im Interesse des Nutzers, muss er halt zustimmen. Das heißt, das wird irgendwann demnächst in Seite achtzehn sein. Aber man muss dann eben auch die Möglichkeit haben, nicht zuzustimmen. Das heißt, dann kann man irgendwie das äh abbestellen. Ähm,
und
Was sie auch haben, wenn es eine wenn es im Rahmen einer Verfolgungsmaßnahme ist, dann ist ein Richterbeschluss dafür notwendig.
Also wenn irgendwie mit DPI-Maßnahmen äh Nutzer überwacht werden sollen oder so. Ähm.
Ist alles echt eine ziemlich saubere Angelegenheit. Kann man Bits of Freedom nur gratulieren. Bits for Freedom ist eines der Vorbilder von
digitale Gesellschaft gewesen bei der Gründung, ist also eine relativ schlagkräftige Lobbytruppe in dem Bereich und die haben, soweit ich das jetzt äh erinnere, auch an diesem Gesetzesentwurf da mitgeschrieben.
Sind ja auch schon wirklich sehr lange im Geschäft, ne?
Die sind ziemlich lange dabei.
Zufrieden, keine Ahnung, zehn Jahre sind die locker dabei, ne?
Es gab, ah, da könnten wir empfehlen, es gab mal einen Podcast, da waren Markus und ich bei dir zu Gast, das ist ungefähr ein Jahr her, da ging es um die Gründung von digitaler Gesellschaft.
Ja, genau genommen war ich bei euch zu Gast.
Aber wir waren hier in der Metaebene. Genau, du warst bei uns, aber.
Wurde es bei Netzpolitik ORG, aber ihr braucht das mal einen Moderator.
Genau, wir brauchen jemanden, der uns die richtigen Fragen stellt. Nee, und da da dieser Podcast hat ja in einer sehr schönen ähm Zusammenfassung der europäischen ganzen Bewegungen und so durch Markus,
gemündet. Und da wird auch, soweit ich mich erinnere, viel zu bitz of Freedom. Ähm erzählt,
grundsätzlich ganz interessant auch so andere Player.
Auch anderen Organisationen. Genau es war ich erinnere mich wieder, es war so ein Überblick überhaupt, wie über die Jahre sich diese einzelnen Organisationen in Deutschland und international überhaupt etabliert haben und was für Arbeitsmethoden die haben.
Wo du es äh erwähnst, habe ich's auch schon wieder ganz plastisch vor meinem geistigen Auge.
Wir verlinken das.
Genau und scheint, wenn ich das Holländisch, es ist nur in der holländischen Wikipedia jetzt gut nachzuschlagen. Da ist aber schon mal das Jahr zweitausend genannt,
ich denke mal, das äh haut hin mit denen agiert schon seit zehn Jahren.
Ja, so sind wir jetzt gespannt, also digitale Gesellschaft hat's natürlich sofort aufgegriffen, jetzt sind überall die PMs, so ja, äh Niederlande gehen als leuchtendes Beispiel voran. Sind, glaube ich,
Das erste europäische Land und das zweite weltweit und jetzt rate mal, welches das erste Land offensichtlich war weltweit?
Das Netzneutralität äh eingeführt hat.
Ja. Per Gesetz habe ich jetzt auch heute zum ersten Mal gelesen, war sehr überrascht.
Habe keine auch nur irgendwie geartete Ahnung.
Würdest du auch wahrscheinlich nie drauf kommen, dass es Chile ist? Schile. Ja, schaffe ich, habe ich heute, stand im Internet, Quelle Internet. Ähm war für mich also auch neu, ja. Schiele.
Kick an.
Das war irgendein, aber ja, Law in Chile, ja.
War weltweit das erste Land. Hätte man jetzt auch nicht gedacht, dass die sich irgendwann mal.
Ja, wir haben ja nicht so viel Plan von Südamerika und Asien, ne. Muss man mal eingestehen. Gut.
Also, Netzneutralität in Holland.
Und Vorratsdatenspeicherung in Deutschland. Wie wär's denn damit?
Das Zweite vom Tischthema äh.
Alles vom Tisch.
Turns out. Äh Brüssel möchte Deutschland jetzt auch weiterhin, wie angekündigt, vorm EuGH verklagen. Allerdings nur auf Strafzahlungen und nicht auf einen Pauschalbetrag,
Unterschied ist, der Pauschalbetrag würde rückwirkend seit äh in Kraft treten der Richtlinie gelten. Das heißt, ähm da die zweitausendacht oder so in Kraft getreten ist,
Würde der Pauschalbetrag Deutschland rückwirkend,
Äh zu einer Zahlung verdonnern, während Strafzahlungen erst Abentscheidungen des EuGH gelten,
Das heißt, da da wird dann jetzt irgendwie dieses Verfahren stattfinden und dann ähm würde der EuGH von mir aus sagen, ja,
also entweder sagt er ja ihr haltet euch nicht an,
Geltende Vereinbarung. Jetzt müsst ihr äh Strafzahlungen leisten. Bei Schweden waren das dreihundertfünfzigtausend Kronen pro Tag.
Ähm und dann haben sie es ja auch äh eingeführt und ähm,
was das halt für Deutschland dann wäre, würde man sehen. Aber es steht ja auch die die Möglichkeit offen, dass der EUGH sagt, ja übrigens äh an anderer Stelle äh wollen wir uns erstmal hier damit auseinandersetzen, ob die ganze Angelegenheit überhaupt ähm rechtens ist,
und ähm prüfen das ohnehin. Also wie auch immer der EuGH da entscheiden will, höchstens steht im steht im Raum als Strafe irgendwie Strafzahlung ab, Urteil des EuGH,
Das heißt, diese gesamte Millionen Panikmache, die ja da von der CDU CSU die ganze Zeit betrieben wurde, stellt sich als ähm.
Ja, Panikmache heraus. Ähm.
Ist er auch irgendwie angeklungen, wann da mit einer Entscheidung zu rechnen ist. Also ist das jetzt so ein Schnelldurchlauf oder kann das jetzt erstmal dauern.
Das wird erstmal dauern. Also da habe ich keine genaue äh Ahnung, wie lange sowas dauert, aber ähm.
Also im Vorratsdatensparung müssen wir uns keine Sorgen mehr machen.
Ja, also das wird jetzt von einigen so interpretiert, dass wir uns das in dieser Legislaturperiode nicht mehr äh dass wir uns da in dieser Legislaturperiode keine Sorgen mehr drum machen müssen. Das also ähm.
Also der Legislaturperiode unserer deutschen Regierung, davon meinst du.
Unserer momentanen Regierung aus FDP und äh CDU und CSU, die wollen ja immer auch nochmal gesondert genannt werden und ähm dass.
Na ja, warten wir mal dieses Wochenende ab. Da sind ja Wahlen in NRW, was der Geier die Haltbarkeits äh das Haltbarkeitsdatum nach diesem Wochenende aussieht.
Ja, also das,
Lassen wir uns mal da jetzt nicht drauf ein, aber also so so sieht's jetzt auf jeden Fall erstmal aus. Also big News, ähm eigentlich genau der Punkt, dass dass einfach Deutschland gar nicht entscheidet in dieser Angelegenheit, die Sache aussitzt
und es kommt keine äh es kommen genau keine großartigen Strafzahlungen. Ähm das ist eingetreten,
Und ähm auch wenn ich selber nicht gedacht hätte, dass es so eintritt und weil ich vor allem,
wie heiß die Debatte irgendwie lief. Ähm andererseits eigentlich nur noch damit zu rechnen war, dass nur genau das eintreten konnte. Bin ich ja trotzdem überrascht und ähm.
Erfreut, dass äh ja, sich rausstellt,
Dass das dieser ganze Strafzahlungsquatsch da ja, dass man da ruhig mal irgendwie müde drüber lächeln konnte und dass sich das auch bewahrheitet hat, dass man da müde drüber lächeln konnte.
Aber worüber soll denn jetzt der EuGH konkret entscheiden?
Der EuGH wird darüber entscheiden und das wird er relativ eindeutig machen, dass Deutschland sich nicht an diese, dass Deutschland diese Richtlinie nicht umgesetzt hat.
Also es geht hier nicht um eine Überprüfung der Richtlinie als solche.
Die ist ja äh gleichzeitig äh anhängig durch dieses Verfahren, was der irische angeleiert hat.
Ja, aber müssten sie dann nicht das erstmal abwarten.
Genau, das ist die Frage. Machen sie, warten sie das ab. Das ist immer Nummer eins. Sie könnten das abwarten. Nummer zwei ist, sie könnten sagen, äh na ja, liebe EU-Kommission, seit einem Jahr wollt ihr diese Richtlinie überarbeiten,
Insofern können wir Deutschland nachvollziehen, dass sie das nicht umsetzen wollen. Also eine eine Richtlinie, die ihr nochmal überarbeiten wollt. Ähm,
Ja, ich weiß nicht, wie der wie der EuGH tickt, aber es geht da erstmal um eine um eine ähm einfache Entscheidung ähm,
Und zwar dann letztendlich eigentlich augenscheinlich erstmal nur um die Höhe des Zwangsgeldes.
Ja.
Dann könnte der EuGH aber wie gesagt argumentieren, na ja, warte mal ab, äh wir haben eigentlich eh vor, die Sache zu kassieren. Insofern ähm,
was weiß ich, äh lassen wir es jetzt erst mal aus, äh lassen wir es erstmal aussetzen oder hängen das hinten an.
Oder der EuGH könnte sagen, ja, wie gesagt, EU-Kommission seht mal zu, dass ihr da euren Kram überhaupt vorab überarbeitet. Dann könnt ihr irgendwann auch von den Leuten verlangen, dass sie's umsetzen. Also
Ich weiß, wie gesagt nicht, wie der da tickt und was da zu erwarten ist, aber insgesamt ist jetzt hier äh keine große Panik anzusagen.
Heißt das, heißt das, dass jetzt eigentlich die Debatte um die Vorratsdatenspeicherung in dieser Legislaturperiode beendet ist.
Das interpretiert zumindest Heribert Brannte in der Süddeutschen Zeitung so. Ähm.
Aber es gibt jetzt kein offizielles Statement äh so in der in dieser Richtung.
Sind die Statements sogar ähm sogar eher dreister oder oder gegenteilig, weil da nämlich gesagt wird, also vor allem von Seiten des Innenministeriums so, nee, nee, nix hier, keine ähm,
Entschärfung und wir wollen das nach wie vor ähm.
Mit den Daten.
Durchhauen und so. Also dass die Debatte erledigt ist ähm.
Kann man so nicht sagen, wage ich jetzt die Prognose nicht, aber zumindest,
Ist der Druck weg aus Brüssel, den ja wie wir uns erinnern, Lokbuch Netzpolitik berichtete, äh sich der Friedrich eigentlich dabei da herbei gewünscht hatte durch seinen Brief. Ähm.
Weil ich glaube, das war auch schon so ein bisschen so äh hilfloses Gewebe mit den Armen. Tja, na ja.
Fehlt da jetzt, es fehlt auf jeden Fall dieser Debatte der Druck. Ich meine, es wird ja nicht jede Debatte, die in Deutschland geführt wird, hat irgendwelchen Druck, wir werden das ja gleich beim Thema vier oder.
Ja gut, aber das heißt dann aber auch, dass sie sich jetzt nicht unbedingt äh klein beigeben und äh dem Vorschlag von Sabine Leuthäuser
Schnarrenberger, da einfach jetzt zustimmen, weil sie ihren anderen Kram nicht durch
sollen sie vertagen den Kram einfach und da erhält dieser Finanzdruck aus der EU jetzt so nicht da ist, kümmern sie sich erstmal wieder um die Banken.
Also man muss eigentlich gucken, wie ähm also man könnte jetzt sagen, so wie fanatisch ist der Friedrich.
Ihm ist jetzt sein sein EU-Argument ist er jetzt weg. Es könnten jetzt natürlich äh die Oles äh Boß, Bäche und Friedriche hingehen und sagen, ja, aber ähm,
Die Ausländer bringen uns alle um oder irgendeine Panik widerfahren und die die VDS trotzdem irgendwie durchdrücken wollen. Ähm ich rechne nur damit, dass sie dass ihnen dann die Angela Merkel sagen würde, ey Freunde, so,
Äh das Spiel haben wir versucht,
Wir hatten den Druck aus Brüssel. Wir haben die große Keule gezogen. Es ist jetzt einfach erstmal politisch nicht mehr geboten. Äh diese Debatte weiterzuführen.
Und ähm das wäre jetzt so ehrlich gesagt meine persönliche Einschätzung,
dass das passieren wird. Aber, wie gesagt, man weiß nicht, wie fanatisch da letztendlich die Leute sind. Und es kann genauso gut sein, dass die jetzt einfach unbeeindruckt ähm weiterfahren und da irgendwie den.
Den Krieg irgendwie weiterführen. Andrester, der ja hier auch schon öfter mal zu Gast warte für Netzpolitik, Org beim Innenministerium angefragt und da war zumindest erstmal die Antwort so, dass man sagte, nichts, wir machen weiter, draufhauen muss alles sofort umgesetzt werden.
Also das offizielle Statement hat sich noch nicht geändert, aber zwischen den Zeilen, wenn man zwischen den Zeilen liest, stellt sich das mittlerweile etwas anders dar
Naja, vielleicht äh artet ja auch diese äh Regierung langsam in so einer Art Beerdigungsunternehmen für äh unrealistische äh Gesetzesvorschläge um,
bringt uns dann auch gleich zum nächsten Thema.
Der Schultrojaner ähm Logbuch Netzpolitik berichtete ähm dieses,
Diese Software, die also auf auf Schulrechnern äh installiert werden sollte, um dort nach
Kopien oder Plagiarden oder wie auch immer Sie das genannt haben, also irgendwie nach, nach digitalen Dateien suchen sollte, die im Unterricht zu nutzen irgendwie nicht den vertraglichen Bedingungen entsprechen würde,
Äh da hat jetzt das bayrische Kultusministerium bekannt gegeben, dass der, dass diese Software äh das von deren Einsatz abgesehen werden soll. Ja, ähm,
gleichzeitig ähm,
hat sich aber an den an den gesamt Bedingungen ja nichts geändert, ja? Also die die Bedingungen, dass dass es nach wie vor in diesem Rahmenvertrag, den sie da haben
die Nutzung dieser Materialien irgendwie sehr stark behindert wird und und dürfen sie irgendwie nicht kopieren und Anzahl von Seiten und ähm was wir da alles auch in einer Folge Logbuch Netzpolitik in aller Breite diskutiert haben
Daran ändert sich natürlich nichts. Insofern ist das äh ja, gut, also kann man jetzt sich drüber freuen, aber was, was den.
Also die okay, also.
Zu Zugang zu zu zu äh.
Wissen betrifft, ist es nach wie vor schwierig. Also die die Regelung ist scheiße, aber zumindest wird ihnen jetzt nicht hinterherspioniert.
Genau, zumindest gibt's keine Trojaner dafür,
Aber äh da gab's ja noch eine kleine, nette Meldung auch heute oder gestern bei Netzpolitik org. Ähm natürlich haben Schulen ja auch irgendwelche Jugend äh Schutzfilter oder so und in NRW ist da ähm,
an einer Schule irgendwie auch ein Filter im Einsatz. Und der zensiert die Piratenpartei,
und zwar wegen ihrer Forderung der Cannabis Legalisierung,
Drogen zu tun und deswegen äh zensiert dieser äh dieser Jugendschutzfilter in in nordrhein-westfälischen Schulen,
Der ist jetzt nicht auf allen Schulen äh denke ich mal. Ich weiß nicht, wie da die Rahmenverträge sind. Aber einer der äh Zensur einer der,
Zensur sage ich schon, der Jugendschutzfilter, die da zum Einsatz kommen, sperrt äh aktuell wohl die Seite der Piraten.
Da steht halt Cannabis Legalisierung.
Müssten sie aber die CDU CSU ja auch sperren, weil die sich dagegen einsetzen, das Thema auch auf der Agenda haben. Ich meine, da könnte man ja gleich alle Parteien sperren, weil die sich überhaupt zu irgendwelchen Themen äußern.
Ja äh ich also ich denke auch, also es eigentlich interessant. Ja, was was macht eine Partei, die sich.
Verfassungsrang hat das äh diese Meinungsbildung übrigens, ne, also.
Ja, also ich denke, also ich gehe eigentlich davon aus, dass wenn am Montag da jemand in die Schule geht, dass dieser Filter geändert sein wird. Ähm aber es ist eine es zeigt natürlich mal wieder so diesen,
hundert Mal durchgekautes Thema, ne, aber was was äh was das irgendwie bedeutet.
So bringen.
Die angefragte Seite ist gesperrt. Äh sie ist dem folgenden Themenbereich zugeordnet, illegale Drogen, ja.
Landtagswahlprogramm der Piratenpartei, das ist wirklich geil.
Also das ist vor allem interessant, wenn man sich überlegt, wenn eine Partei hingeht und irgendetwas ändern möchte.
Dann, also jeder Gesetzesvorschlag oder Gesetzesänderungsvorschlag.
Ist ja erstmal verboten dann, ne? Ja. Ist illegal.
Ist erstmal verboten. Ist illegal, ja. Wir wollen Steuern senken. Na, ist illegal. Gesetz ist Steuern sind so und so, ja. Also könnte man äh könnte man dann irgendwie FDP sein.
Ist jetzt vielleicht nicht das beste Beispiel, aber keine Ahnung, Prostitution et cetera, ähnliche Gemengelage.
Prostitution. Ja, wir wollen äh ja, also.
Hand in Hand, Handeln, Hand in Hand heißt hier die äh Aktion. Eine Aktion für ein sauberes, sauberes Internet.
Internet, ja. Time for Kids, ja.
Leute, das ist alles, das ist alles digitale Bits, da gibt's nur Nullen und eins, da gibt's kein Staub. Da gibt's keinen Dreck, kein Schmutz.
Pornografie, Drogen und Gewalt müssen Schüler nicht mehr ertragen. Ja, ich ich sehe auch, also man sieht ja immer die Schüler, ne, die irgendwie die ganze Pornographie ertragen müssen, die sie sich mit vierzehn und fuffzehn erwürfelt hat er das angucken, ja. Die sind völlig fertig.
Ja, können's nicht mehr ertragen, ja. Die ganze Pornographie und die Drohung, die sie sich reinfahren, ja.
Vor allem irgendwie im Pausenhof die ganze Zeit gekifft und jetzt auch noch im Internet.
Könnte ich also die sind froh die Kinder, dass sie das nicht mehr ertragen.
Ja, da sind sie wirklich glücklich. Oh Mann, Leute, get a life. Naja, gut.
Gibt's da noch was zu sagen zu dem Schultrojaner? Ich glaub das mussten wir unter LNP berichtete,
bringt uns dann zu unserem aktuellen Lieblingsthema, wo wir alle schon so leicht das gähnen kriegen.
Ja.
Täglich grüßt das Urheberrecht,
Es vergeht kein Tag, wo nicht wieder irgendeine hinterm Ofen hervorgezogene, beliebige Gruppe von irgendwelchen Urhebern, von irgendwas sich beklagt, dass ja das, was kein Mensch fordert, ja, nicht stattfinden darf,
Das finde ich überhaupt am geilsten, ja, dieses Urheberrecht soll abgeschafft werden. Wer hat das eigentlich überhaupt in die Welt getragen? Und wie lässt sich vor allem die Piratenpartei, der das ja immer unterstellt wird? Sie würde das unterstützen
ähm wie geht die da eigentlich damit um, dass die ganze Zeit irgendwas behauptet wird, was einfach niemand
Also gibt's irgendjemand außer MS Pro vielleicht, der tatsächlich sagt, man sollte das Urheberrecht abschaffen.
Debatte, unabhängig davon, ob das sinnvoll ist oder nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ein gewisser Artikel, von dem ich gerade am Telefon erfahren habe, äh schon veröffentlicht ist. Da gibt's dann noch jemanden, der es fordert. Aber ähm nein, natürlich nicht.
Aber es gibt keine politische Partei, die das in irgendeiner Form.
Politische Partei, die es irgendwo fordert und die Piratenpartei
Parteiprogramm ist ja ich hab das ja auch schon mehrmals hier betont absolut wischi waschi in der Angelegenheit ja? Die sind ja ich glaub da haben sogar die Grünen haben im Moment 'ne radikalere Position zur Urheberrechtsnovelle als die Piraten.
Das war jetzt so dahergesagt, aber die Piraten haben nirgendwo stehen, dass sie es ab äh schaffen wollen, ja? Und setzen sich ja auch in.
In ihrer in ihrer politischen Arbeit mit ganz anderen Themen durcheinander auseinander, ja. Es gibt irgendwie keinen
Piraten, der irgendwo hingeht und und ungefragt irgendwie gegen das Urheberrecht wartet, ja. Es gibt Piraten, die dann eingeladen werden in in Fernsehsendungen. Es gibt übrigens äh große äh Empfehlungen hier von meiner Seite den Bruno,
Kram, Bono Gert Kram, ähm der ja auch irgendwie da zuletzt bei dieser Sat.1 Sendung war ähm,
Ein Musikproduzent oder Labelbetreiber und Piratenmitglied ähm der also sowas von komprimiert,
Auf den Punkt äh Urheberrechtskritik oder oder Kritik am bestehenden Urheberrechts und äh bestehenden äh Entfertungsentgeltungs äh Modellen übt Verwertungsmodellen.
Verwertungs. Mhm.
Also wirklich 'ne eine hochinteressante Person.
Der sich halt aktiv bei den Piraten jetzt auch.
Der sich da aktiv mit dem Thema auseinandersetzt, aber selbst der geht ja nirgendwo ungefragt hin,
dann angerufen und dann dann kommt er ins Radio und wird gesagt, ja hier Urheberrecht, sagen sie mal was dazu so. Und dann sagt er sehr schlaue Dinge äh und dann dann liegt er auf, ja, aber der ist ja der der rennt ja jetzt nicht irgendwie nach vorne und sagt hier irgendwie
Nazivergleich äh Spiegelseite eins und Urheberrecht oder so, ja. Also da wurde echt irgendwie auf äh von von weit drauf irgendwie auch ja völlig aus dem,
Wie gesagt, es war irgendwie Markus, hatte das auf Netzpolitik schon gesagt. Da kommt jetzt eine Welle,
Und die ist orchestriert und daran besteht ja auch heute wirklich gar keinen Zweifel mehr. Wen hatten wir alles? Wir hatten wir hatten Sven Regener, okay, das war irgendwie sein Nachmittagsding. Dann hatten wir die einundfünfzig Tatortoren. Dann hatten wir,
immer mehr, die Dezimalstellen ändern sich. Wir sind ja jetzt vierstellig. Jetzt müssen's ja tausend sein. Also wir haben ja jetzt irgendwie offenen Brief, wir sind die ähm.
Urheber und direkt mit viel mehr viel tausendmal mehr Unterzeichnern heute, morgen irgendwie an Start gegangen, wir sind die Bürger,
Also eine eine schöne äh Kampagne, äh wo man dann auch unterschreiben kann, ein ähm ein eine Forderung für ein,
Zeitgemäßes Urheberrecht,
auch da nicht. Wir wollen kein Urheberrecht. Also es fehlt eigentlich jetzt so, ich denke mal, es wird auch nicht lange auf sich warten lassen. Es fehlt ja jetzt irgendwie, wir sind die Rauchkopierer.
Petition, die wird jetzt auch noch kommen, Erdi. Und wenn wenn MS Pro, die morgen startet, also irgendeiner holt die noch aus dem Hut. Das war jetzt nur eine Frage, die hatten jetzt alle keine Zeit, ne. Aber ähm.
Oh Mann, wir sind die Roboter.
Also.
Es jetzt erstmal also Tatortautoren, dann kam irgendwie Handelsblatt, hatten wir ähm und jetzt gibt's irgendwie Zeit und und überall schießt das irgendwie raus und es es bluten einem die Augen und die Ohren, weil die Debatte völlig unterirdisch verläuft.
Ja und dann auch so viele Leute, die vom Fernsehen leben, öffentlich, rechtlich, die irgendwie von der GEZ äh äh profitieren et cetera, also die die,
Ja, also mir fällt da auch schon fast nichts mehr zu ein. Also da beschweren sich einfach Leute, ne, ich meine, hier jetzt hat sich auch noch diese Charlotte,
oder Rotsch, Rotsch ist vielleicht in dem Zusammenhang der bessere Name,
äh die ich an sich finde sehr charmante äh Moderatorin halte, ja, vielleicht.
Verstehe ich irgendwas nicht, was ihre Person betrifft. Ich habe mich auch nicht sonderlich intensiv mit ihr beschäftigt.
Ja, dieses Buchautorin, die hat da ihren Bestseller was was befürchtet die eigentlich? Ja, ich meine, das Buch,
und verkauft sich ihr Buch schlecht irgendwie nicht, ja? Es geht irgendwie millionenfach weg und äh vielleicht hat das auch was damit zu tun, dass es irgendwie auf ist.
Und das ist das, das ist das, was mich so ein bisschen auch ähm im Kopf schütteln lässt, das einfach manche Leute da einfach versehen, aber,
Ich meine, diese Urheber, die scheinen ja auch genauso planfrei zu sein, wie die meisten, die sich sonst auch noch an dieser Debatte
beteiligen und es ist halt einfach ein aufgestachelt. Wir hatten das ja schon bei dieser Tatortgeschichte, dass da einfach ein ganz klarer Aktionismus war, da sollte eine Agenda gesetzt werden, dass diese Leute da ausgegraben worden, die hätten sich von alleine nicht so ohne Weiteres aus dem Grab erhoben.
Die werden da relativ offensichtlich von Karren gespannt, ja? Auch dieses äh Zeit Ding jetzt mit wir sind die Urheber, das ist auch wieder initiiert worden von einem Literaturagenten.
Landwehr. Ja,
äh und das geht irgendwie los, der erste Satz irgendwie mit Sorge und Unverständnis verfolgen wir als Autorin und Künstler, die,
öffentlichen Angriff auf das Urheberrecht. Und das ist genau das, was also was ganz offensichtlich nicht passiert. Es rennt keiner hin und hat das hat Urheberrecht auf die Agenda gesetzt, außer jene, ähm die Urheberrechte verwerten,
Ja, aber äh MS Pro schrieb heute auch nochmal in seinem in einem Artikel, der sonst jetzt nicht so viel geheilt hatte, äh,
Für uns ist das eine Debatte, ja, die führen wir mal aus Spaß, die spüren wir abends beim Bierchen, die führen wir in unserem Podcast. Für sie ist das eine Existenzfrage. Das stimmt natürlich, den die haben ein bisschen mehr Muffe am sausen,
als wir. Wenn man sich mal.
Ja, die haben die Muffe am sausen, die Frage ist nur, ob sie äh begründet da die Muffe am sausen haben. Ich meine, es gibt ja äh
durchaus valide Punkte in dieser ganzen Debatte, die von allen Seiten gemacht werden. Jeder hat da irgendetwas und sicherlich ist jetzt nicht äh also mit so einer
radikal, Piratenbuchteinstellung, mit alles muss ich jetzt jederzeit von jedem, jederzeit irgendwie verwendet werden, wie er möchte. Das führt ist es genauso wenig zielführend wie die äh äh welche Idee auch immer mal in meinem Hirn zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt entsp
ist, äh muss bis in alle Ewigkeit äh für mich arbeiten. Ja, also das sind so diese beiden Superextreme, aber ich sehe auch, dass diese Urheber dann auch einfach häufig
überhaupt nix verstehen. Also ich habe da irgendwie mal so ein kann jetzt leider keine Quelle nennen, das lief glaube ich irgendwie auf Deutschlandfunks. Ich hatte das im Radio und,
und dann halt auch so es ging dann um die Reduzierung.
Urheberrecht, das muss man sich immer mal wieder klarmachen, gilt bis siebzig Jahre nach dem Tod von irgendjemandem.
Wollten sie es auf.
So und dann genau und dann kam so ins Feld äh eine Piratenforderung, eine Piratenforderung, keine Ahnung, ob das noch irgendwie.
Das ist die, das sind die dreißig Jahre aus dem Parteiprogramm.
Dreißig Jahre beziehungsweise da waren dann irgendwie sieben Jahre in dem Moment in der Diskussion. Ja, also wie gesagt, jede Diskussion läuft so ein bisschen anders. In dem Moment, was halt einfach mal sieben Jahre,
auch etwas, womit ich mich anfreunden könnte so, aber ne, das muss äh den Realitäts,
machen so. Dann irgendwie cut und dann wieder so O-Töne von irgendjemanden, da meinte einer so,
Wie das Urheberrecht soll nur noch sieben Jahre gelten. Ja, äh das ist ja viel zu wenig. Wie soll ich denn da äh ja, also überhaupt nicht verstanden,
dass nach dem Tod und nach der Schaffung einfach mal zwei
grundsätzlich, ich meine, ist überhaupt schon erstaunlich, dass es ein Recht gibt, was den eigenen Tod überlebt, ja? Also das ist normalerweise entfällt wirklich eine Menge
in dem Moment, ja? Ich habe dann irgendwie kein, kein Besitz mehr und so, also man kann das dann zwar vererben, gut,
Darauf basiert ja auch diese ganze Verlängerungs äh äh Debatte, aber es hat sich halt natürlich auch einfach gezeigt, dass siebzig Jahre mittlerweile in dieser Welt,
Was war vor siebzig Jahren, ja? Was haben wir.
Bei den siebzig Jahre Sachen,
Da greift halt wirklich einfach mal, also da spätestens greift dieses Argument, dass ähm die Nutzung von Kultur einfach dadurch nur noch verhindert wird, ja, also etwas, was siebzig Jahre alt ist, das äh,
ist einfach nicht mehr sinnvoll kapitalistisch zu verwerten.
Micky Maus.
Ja und wenn es das noch ist, dann lässt es sich nicht ernsthaft rechtfertigen, warum es noch sinnvoll kapitalistisch zu verwerten ist.
Beziehungsweise worum's denn nicht auch alle sinnvoll kapitalistisch verwerten sollten, weil irgendwann ist halt dieser Urheber dann halt auch mal weg. So und hat das nur gehoben.
Wir werden das jetzt nicht äh, dass wir wir werden das jetzt irgendwie nicht so äh lösen hier heute. Aber es nervt, es nervt.
Wir können diese Debatte nicht zu Ende führen. Ja, es ist krass.
Und meint, ich bin wirklich erstaunt,
Also ich bin wirklich erstaunt. Das ist etwas, was mir auch ein bisschen, was mich echt wirklich einfach nur stauen und äh bisschen mit staunen lässt, so ein bisschen mit Sorge erfüllt ist,
ohne dass es einen konkreten Punkt dafür gäbe.
Prasselt diese Kampagne in einem ungeahnten Ausmaß irgendwie gerade aus allen Kanälen auf uns ein.
Und da bin ich echt sehr sehr,
Erstaunt, aber hätte ich nicht für möglich gehalten, dass das so in so einer Breite und aus aus allen Rohren und alle kommen sie daher und
und hauen irgendeinen Quatsch raus. Ich meine, es gab irgendwie, das ist leider ein bisschen untergegangen, wollte äh dem gebührt eine Erwähnung am Tag des geistigen Eigentums veröffentlichte das Syndikat, ein Zusammenschluss von irgendwie sechshundert Krimiautorinnen und Autoren, diese Fotos
ähm nackt in der Gerichtsmedizin und hatten dann irgendwie so Überschriften ja äh Seelenräuber und hatten dann irgendwie,
acht Krimiautoren, die dann irgendwie in in der in diesem Gerichtsmedizinsaal lagen und dann kam irgendwie einer mit einer enormen Maske und nahmen denen das Herz weg oder so. Also du völlig äh,
also völlig, völlig drüber, also auch geschmacklos, ja, also die sahen auch wirklich scheiße aus, diese Poster, ja, haben sie irgendwie also,
ekelhaft, ja und und so eine Verdrehung und und.
Ja, es ist, es ist schon, es ist schon wirklich ein bisschen absurd, ähm wie da dem Ball gegangen wird. Ich muss aber auch sagen, oder du hast es eben auch schon so ein bisschen rausgestellt, was ich
Was ich ganz gut finde, ist die Sache,
kommt einfach in Bewegung. Also so sehr ein jetzt die Debatte als solche und die Argumente und die Kampagnen, äh die da in dem Zusammenhang definitiv gefahren werden. Nervt und ankretzt und man's nicht mehr hören kann und was nicht alles,
Wir haben eine Debatte,
Das finde ich überhaupt schon mal einen extremen Gewinn. Ich meine, es ist jetzt irgendwie, wir sind mit einem Jahre drei nach Zensursular, ja. Man kann das, glaube ich, mittlerweile schon so ein bisschen als äh ähm,
Urknall äh der modernen Kulturdebatte, zumindest in diesem Land äh mal festhalten, ja, auf also ich meine, da hätten wir uns doch nicht.
Du da auch nur irgendwas drauf gewettet, dass auch irgendeins dieser Themen, die wir hier jetzt hier gerade haben? In waren wir vor ein paar Monaten noch total baff,
dass das jetzt auf einmal ein Thema ist. Mittlerweile ist es ja schon fast zu einem super Thema,
hochgekocht, ja? Es war bis vor kurzem noch überhaupt nicht denkbar, dass man sich über sowas überhaupt unterhält. Mittlerweile kommt alles das auf den Tisch und insofern muss man den Zeitungen vielleicht auch an der Stelle mal so sehr sie da im Interessenkonflikt sind,
Ich finde das schon mal grundsätzlich gut,
das überhaupt über die Medien so eine Debatte geführt wird und dass sie auch in zunehmenden Maße äh äh wenn auch mit Anpassungsschwierigkeiten auch mit dem Netz geführt wird und zunehmendem Maße auch in dem Netz geführt wird, nicht nur bei uns,
sondern auch an anderen Stellen,
und äh das kann ich jetzt erstmal alles nur gutheißen. Ja, ich bin überzeugt, dass da auch irgendwas bei rauskommen wird, weil irgendwann muss der Knoten beim Thema Urheberrecht auch mal äh geknackt werden,
Nämlich, wahrscheinlich wird das genau in dem Moment stattfinden, wo dann auch jeder akzeptiert hat, dass da ein Problem ist. Weil ich glaube, das ist, glaube ich, auch noch so ein bisschen das, wo es einfach fehlt.
Das wird über alle möglichen Aspekte geredet, alle Leute äh haben ihre Horrorszenarien, diese schön an die Wand malen und am Ende könnte erstmal stehen so,
Wenn da so viel heiße Luft erzeugt wird, ja und so viel äh Kohlendioxid äh auch ausgegeben wird im äh in der Folge.
Dann ist es ja wohl offensichtlich, dass da was im Argen ist. So und das ist ja schon mal eine sehr interessante Erkenntnis, als als Grundlage für,
eine etwas intelligenter geführte äh Debatte. Ich denke, die Piraten haben mittlerweile auch verstanden, dass sie da zwar,
Potenzielles Kernthema haben, was sich bei ihnen aber noch etwas entkernt,
anfühlt so und müssen dem halt beigehen aber auch die anderen Parteien merken dass sie da eigentlich auch,
nicht so richtig Bescheid wissen so. Die Debatte wird dann halt auch damit in die Parteien getragen.
Äh also da hast du absolut recht, dass das was schönes ist, dass diese Debatte stattfindet. Aber ich erinnere an unsere Folge äh,
Die Achillesverse,
Ja, weil das äh und das wäre dann jetzt, um unserem, in der Sendung Nummer dreiundzwanzig auch nochmal äh gerecht zu werden. Ähm das wäre natürlich ein sinnvoller Grund,
diese oder diese Debatte Urheberrecht jetzt auch von Seiten der Rechteverwerter heute oder zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt zum Showdown zu bringen,
wo die gegnerische Seite äh immer noch,
ein bisschen ähm Modelle schuldig bleibt, ähm zu zeigen, dass es eben auch im weitgehenden Verzicht auf das Urheberrecht oder auf die Rechte, die damit einhergehen Geschäftsmodelle gibt.
Also beispielsweise ähm also es gibt einfach es konnte bis jetzt noch keiner zeigen,
Bis auf sehr wenige Ausnahmen, die äh sich nicht unbedingt als besonders repräsentativ ähm erweisen sollten, dass ähm im weitgehenden Verzicht auf Urheberrechte ähm,
großartig nennenswertes Geschäftsmodell entspringt, was nicht nur vereinzelt Personen, sondern für viele funktionieren sollte.
Und so sehr ich auch der Ansicht bin, dass ein äh Musiker, es ist ja immer ein Beispiel der Musik, dass ein Musiker vielleicht nicht ein Leben lang von einem Hit
leben können müsste, um diese Gesellschaft zu einer gerechten zu machen. Ähm,
So haben die natürlich im Moment, sage ich mal, ihre auf der einen Seite ihre Verwerter, die sagen, guck mal hier, äh wir bieten euch ähm.
Diese und jene rechtliche Sicherheit,
Sei es sei komme dabei am Ende auch Geld für euch raus oder nicht, aber wir bieten euch die Sicherheit und auf der anderen Seite müssen sie sich fragen, was haben die Fans äh jeweils für uns getan, ja? Ähm also es,
ich bleibe dabei, mein man ist in dieser Debatte als äh Bürgerrechtler oder Urheberrechtskritiker ähm,
bleibt man bisher die empirischen Belege ein bisschen schuldig. Und das sehe ich, also das wäre dann so die meine Verschwörungstheoretischer Ansatz,
um zu erklären, warum die Debatte jetzt geführt wird und nicht erst in drei Jahren.
Ja. Haben wir's, was? Minus.
Ich wollte noch auf den, auf einen, also neben äh diesen ganzen Kampagnen und den schönen Bildern, die wir alle verlinkt haben, noch auf den Text ich bin Urheber von ähm John F Nebel,
auf Metronaut DE hinweisen. Der heute schön die Runde machte und der.
Indem er so schön sagt ähm Moment wo steht's?
Ich bin dagegen, dass Kunst und Kreatives schaffen auf kapitalistische Wertschöpfung reduziert werden und dann auch mal darstellt, was er alles so an so urgehoben hat in den letzten Jahren,
Und das könnte ich mir als einen sehr äh fruchtbare Position in dieser Debatte vorstellen. Deshalb empfehle ich diesen Text.
Mhm. Ja. Und wir wir machen weiter.
Wir machen weiter. Also ich würde sagen, wir holen uns jetzt mal einen drei D Drucker und nachdem wir jetzt schon das ganze geistige Eigentum kopiert haben, fangen wir mit dem Physischen an, weil dann geht's erst richtig los.
Ja, solange hier keiner unseren Podcast.
Dann werden die merken, der hat aber hier mein mein Dings geklaut. Ja, was ist ja noch da. Ja, ist aber trotzdem geklaut, also das werde ich auf jeden Fall mal schön.
Ja, dann bleibt uns eigentlich nicht mehr sehr viel mehr als äh äh uns nochmal für die Unterstützung zu bedanken. Auch die äh der Zuspruch, der sich nicht nur aber auch bei der Republika so äh uns,
hat.
Also herzlichen Dank, meinen Aufruf, mir Bier auszugeben.
Hast du dann noch ein Bier bekommen?
Ein Bier.
Okay. Also nee, das äh hat funktioniert.
Also nee, das äh hat funktioniert, ja, also äh hat geklappt. Vielleicht sogar ein bisschen.
Zwischenzeitlich hast du dich hast du dich ein bisschen beklagt, aber dann so gegen Ende haben dann alle noch ihre Schuld beglichen sozusagen und dann warst du durch.
Ich habe dann ähm noch mal zwischenzeitlich kurz ein Foto getwittert, um es den Leuten zu erleichtern. Ja und dann äh ging das Foto von mir, ja.
Ein Foto. Ein Foto von mir. Wie du.
Da ohne Bier sitze.
Und dann ging das auf einmal äh ganz gut. Und auch nette Leute dabei kennengelernt. Schönen Gruß an dieser Stelle nochmal an alle und ja, eure Publikation. Also hat gerade funktioniert, ja.
Ja, ich äh kann mich auch nicht beklagen. Das war eine nette Veranstaltung und das war's hier mit unserem netten Podcast. Wir sagen.
Hinweise ich nochmal. Thema hat ein Thema hat einen guten Vortrag gehalten. Ich habe ihn leider nicht gesehen, über über das Podcast.
Weißt du, dass er gut war, wenn er nicht gesehen ist.
Weil alle sagen war gut und wenn alle sagen stimmt das. Und äh es gab dann mehrere Artikel äh unter anderem auch auf Zeit Online und so, wo ähm die die Podcasts,
gelobt wurden, ja.
Ja, das war interessant, dass das überhaupt aufgenommen wurde. Ich fühlte mich das erste Mal äh auf einer Republiker nicht komplett in, wie soll ich sagen, in der Isolation,
Thema hat das erste Mal ein bisschen äh Aufmerksamkeit erzeugt. Ich rede mir ja schon seit Jahren den Mund fusselig, aber Zeitenwende.
Steht an.
Zeiten wünsche ich dir dann.
Na gut, jetzt war aber fertig, wa?
Ich bin fertig. Mach mal Schluss hier.
Ich bin auch fertig. Leute, bis bald.